Welcome to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidhanatham. I did a story this past weekend for the public radio show This American Life. The story was in an episode titled The Heart Once What It Wants. We're going to take the whole podcast today to share this unusual story with you. It's a little longer than usual and best heard in a single sitting, so we're going to give it to you without any interruptions. The story is about a con that unfolded very slowly over two decades. The thing that fascinated me about this story is that when the con was finally exposed, many of the victims were heartbroken. They wanted it to go on. They wanted to keep believing.
欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。上周末我在公共广播节目《这美妙的一生》里做了一个故事。这个故事出自一集名为《心之所向》的节目。今天我们将用整期播客来和大家分享这个不同寻常的故事。它比平时稍微长一点，最好一次性听完，所以我们不会中途打断。这个故事关于一场历时二十年、进展极其缓慢的骗局。这个故事最令我着迷的地方在于，当骗局最终被揭穿时，许多受害者都心碎了。他们希望骗局继续下去。他们想要继续相信。
So here's how the con worked. Guys around the country signed up for a penpal service. It would put them in touch with women they could be friend and car is part with. And then they'd start to receive letters. They come from Hillsdale, Illinois, and some of them are white, pink, green. Jesse is a sweet, soft-spoken man with thick plastic aviator glasses. He started receiving the letters in 1985 when he was in his 30s.
事情的经过是这样的。全国各地的单身汉注册了一项笔友服务。这项服务能让他们联系到可以交朋友、倾诉心声的女性。然后，他们就会开始收到信件。这些信件来自伊利诺伊州的希尔斯代尔，有些是白色的、粉色的、绿色的。杰西是一个温和、轻声细语的男子，戴着一副厚厚的塑料飞行员眼镜。他从1985年三十多岁时开始收到这些信件。
Back then he was overweight. He'd never had a serious girlfriend, always lived with his parents. After his mother died, he spent most of his time taking care of his sick dad and working at his family's restaurant. Jesse's favorite letters came from a woman named Pamela. I guess I usually took it at the end of the day when I got him in the mail, went into my room, and laid on my bed and just sat there and read him. Dear Jessie, deep down you know as well as I do that you could be a lot better off than you are
那时候他超重了。他从来没有过认真的女朋友，一直和父母住在一起。母亲去世后，他大部分时间都在照顾生病的父亲，并在家族餐馆里工作。杰西最喜欢的信件来自一个叫帕梅拉的女人。我想我通常是在一天结束时收到信后拿回房间，躺在床上，坐在那里读起来。亲爱的杰西，内心深处你和我都清楚，你的生活本可以过得更好，
if you only had someone on your side. Someone who would help you encourage you work with you and stick with you even when things get bad. When I'm talking about of course as a true friend but that kind of person is hard to find today isn't it. Jesse had never met or talked to Pamela but he was curious. He wrote back telling her a little about himself, and Pamela replied again and again. The letters were typed in a ghoulish font and signed in a blue pen with big, loopy letters. In another letter, Pamela wrote, just before I sat down to write this letter to you, I
只要你身边能有个支持你的人。一个会帮助你、鼓励你、与你并肩作战、即使在情况糟糕时也对你不离不弃的人。我所说的当然是一个真正的朋友，但这种人在如今很难找到，不是吗？杰西从未见过或交谈过帕梅拉，但他很好奇。他回信向她简单介绍了自己，帕梅拉一次又一次地回复。信是用一种怪异的字体打印的，并用蓝色钢笔签上了巨大、连笔的字母。在另一封信中，帕梅拉写道，就在我坐下来给你写这封信之前，我
was thinking how lucky I am that in this great, big, crazy world, I found you. I hope I can be part of your life for a long time, darling, and I hope as time goes by, I'll be able to make you happier and happier. This mystery woman seemed to know him. She made Jesse feel understood. She made him feel loved. You can tell when you meet a person that they're not superficial, this is coming from their heart.
一直在想，在这个宏大、疯狂的世界里能找到你，我是多么幸运。我希望自己能长时间成为你生活的一部分，亲爱的，我希望随着时间推移，我能让你越来越快乐。这个神秘的女人似乎很了解他。她让杰西感到被理解。她让他感到了被爱。你和一个人见面时就能看出他们并不肤浅，这是发自内心的。
Everybody's looking for that perfect love and everything. And this pops up, so I thought, well, could this be something different? This was Pamela. He was mid-laid, balding, and had a small grey mustache. His real name was Don Lowry. Was any of it difficult to come up with these characters if the characters bore you? Tell me about it as a writing project.
每个人都在寻找那种完美的爱情之类的一切。而这个突然出现，所以我想，好吧，这会不会是某种不一样的东西？这就是帕梅拉。他当时处于中年，谢顶，留着一撮灰白的小胡子。他的真名叫唐·洛里。如果这些角色让你厌烦，创作这些角色有什么困难吗？跟我讲讲把它当成一个写作项目吧。
No, I was looking at 40 graphic girls. They were like, what kind of girl is this? Where is she from? What is she like to do? It was fairly easy after a while. The first 20 were a little bit rough, but the next 80 were not hard at all. Anyway, enjoyed making up these characters. I loved it. I loved it. I met that.
不，我当时在看40个平面模特女孩。她们就像是，这是个什么样的女孩？她来自哪里？她喜欢做什么？过了一段时间这变得相当容易。前20个有点艰难，但接下来的80个一点也不难。不管怎样，我很享受捏造这些角色。我爱死它了。我太喜欢了。我遇到了那个。
Don died in 2014, but I met him in 2011 in a rundown house in Butler, Pennsylvania. He was 82. If you have trouble understanding Don's voice, it's because he was a lifelong, heavy smoker. The desk in his living room was covered with ash. His sofa smelled of smoke. Don told me he always wanted to be a writer, but his real talent wasn't being a hustler. He always had a scheme going. In his early thirties, Don visited Mexico and wrote a traveler's guide where he explained
唐于2014年去世，但我是在2011年宾夕法尼亚州巴特勒的一栋破旧房子里见到他的。他当时82岁。如果你听不懂唐的声音，那是因为他是个抽了一辈子烟的老烟枪。他客厅的桌子上布满了烟灰。他的沙发闻起来有烟味。唐告诉我，他一直想成为一名作家，但他真正的天赋不是写作，而是一个骗子。他总是在搞各种阴谋。三十岁出头时，唐访问了墨西哥并写了一本旅行指南，他在书中解释了
how American men could live cheaply there, pick up women, and get by with rudimentary Spanish. It was called Mexico backwards paradise. It didn't sell. And then he tried something, most writers would never consider. He changed the name of the book's author to a woman's name. Sales開rocketed, he said. Apparently, lonely American men didn't want tips from a guy, they wanted tips from a girl.
美国男人如何在当地廉价生活、泡妞，并靠着半生不熟的西班牙语混日子。这本书叫《墨西哥逆向天堂》。它没有卖出去。然后他尝试了一件大多数作家绝对不会考虑的事情。他把书的作者名字改成了一个女性的名字。他说，销量火箭般飙升。显然，孤独的美国男人不需要一个男人的建议，他们想要一个女孩的建议。
Don realized there was a market waiting to be exploited. He rented mailing lists for magazines that cater to single men and started writing letters to them, posing as different women. Men like Jesse were invited to join a club where, in exchange for a small fee, they could receive love letters. In a moment of inspiration, Don decided to call the women who wrote the letters, angels, Angel Linda, Angel Christina, Angel Palma. He purchased stock photos of models and printed catalogs with photos and bios for each angel. Angels came in different flavors. Some were compliant, helpless and pure.
唐意识到有一个等待被开发的市场。他租用了迎合单身男性的杂志的订阅名单，并开始冒充不同的女性给他们写信。像杰西这样的男人被邀请加入一个俱乐部，在那里，只需支付少量费用，他们就可以收到情歌。在灵光一闪的时刻，唐决定将那些写信的女性称为“天使”，天使琳达、天使克里斯蒂娜、天使帕尔马。他购买了模特的库存照片，并为每个天使印刷了带有照片和个人简介的目录。天使们有不同的风格。有些顺从、无助且纯洁。
Others were raunchy and sent nude photos of themselves. Most were young and all were eager to please. Dream women for a certain kind of man, dreamed up of course, by another man. In one brochure, Angel Linda Scott is pictured in a one-piece swimsuit on her hands and knees. Angel Christina looks like an idealistic woman. She is shown hugging a tree and holding a flower. I prefer a certain type of man, Christina says. He can pick up a handful of dark, rich soil and feel a kind of reverence and joy. But he's awfully hard to find.
另一些则很淫荡，会寄出自已的裸照。大多数都很年轻，而且都急于取悦他人。对于某种类型的男人来说，这是梦想中的女人，当然，是由另一个男人梦想出来的。在一份宣传册中，天使琳达·斯科特身穿一件连体泳衣，正跪在地上。天使克里斯蒂娜看起来像一个理想主义的女性。画面中她正拥抱着一棵树，手里拿着一朵花。克里斯蒂娜说：“我更喜欢某种类型的男人。”他可以抓起一把黑暗、肥沃的泥土，感受到一种敬畏和喜悦。但他实在太难找了。
Don male these brochures to men like Jesse. If a man wrote back, Don began sending letters to him as Angel Christina or Angel Linda. Don told me he didn't want members who were just looking for sex. He wanted men looking for meaningful relationships who would be in it for the long haul. He thought this would be better for business and better for the marks. Yeah, the guy, his wife died, you know, and he was living alone. He didn't have any friends.
唐把这些宣传册寄给像杰西这样的男人。如果有人回信，唐就开始以天使克里斯蒂娜或天使琳达的名义给他写信。唐告诉我，他不想招募那些只为了性关系的会员。他想要寻找那些渴望建立有意义的关系、并愿意长久坚持下去的男人。他认为这对业务更好，对这些受骗者也更好。是的，这个家伙，他的妻子去世了，你知道的，他一个人生活。他没有任何朋友。
You know, that kind of thing. He needed this. He didn't have anything or anybody else to trim up. Nobody. We didn't. These girls would boost their egos. You know, things like, all your handwriting is so masculine. Things like that. Little things. Give the guy a boost. And they loved it.
你知道，诸如此类的事情。他需要这个。他没有任何其他人或任何东西来振作起来。没有任何人。我们没有。这些女孩会提升他们的自尊心。你知道，比如，你的字写得真有男人味。诸如此类的话。一些小事。给这家伙打打气。他们很喜欢这样。
After a few letters of Jesse, Pamela let him know that the only thing she wanted was a little help. Darling, I want you to know that I really love writing you every day. It has filled a great need in my life and I know I'd be very sad if I had to stop writing you and being your friend. I hope you feel the same way about me and my letters to you. I think it's fair and reasonable for me to ask you to help with the expenses of paper, envelopes, postage, photos, and the other things I'll be sending you. If you could send me just $10 a week for my letters, I could continue writing every day as I have been. Jesse was fine with that. He figures he sent in four or five thousand dollars between 1985 and 88. It wasn't a big deal to him.
在给杰西写了几封信后，帕梅拉让他知道她想要的只是一点点帮助。亲爱的，我想让你知道，我真的很喜欢每天给你写信。它填补了我生活中的巨大需求，我知道如果我不得不停止给你写信、不再做你的朋友，我会非常难过的。我希望你对我和我写给你的信也有同样的感受。我认为我要求你帮担负一些纸张、信封、邮资、照片以及我将寄给你的其他东西的费用，是公平且合理的。如果你能每周只寄给我10美元作为信件费用，我就能像以前一样继续每天给你写信。杰西对此没有异议。他算了一下，从1985年到1988年间，他寄出了四五千美元。这对他来说不是什么大不了的事。
My business was prospering pretty well. We ran over a hundred thousand dollars three years in a row so there was no problem for me to be sending money and stuff. Pamela often sent Jesse stories about the two of them for a little extra money. In one, Pamela and Jesse go on a picnic together. In another, he literally rescues her as a knight in shining armor. This one story that has them both lying on a bear skin rug in front of a fireplace. And of course, it goes where you think it will go if two people are lying on a bear skin rug in front of a fireplace. But it's romantic. Not explicit. The language is tame. The letter concludes,
我的生意一直很兴隆。我们连续三年营业额超过十万美元，所以我寄钱之类的一点问题也没有。帕梅拉经常给杰西发送一些关于他们两个人的小故事，只需要一点额外费用。其中一个故事里，帕梅拉和杰西一起去野餐。在另一个故事里，他像个身穿闪亮铠甲的骑士一样把她从困境中解救出来。还有一个故事让他们俩躺在壁炉前的熊皮地毯上。当然，如果两个人躺在壁炉前的熊皮地毯上，事情就会向你想象的方向发展。但这是浪漫的，并不露骨。语言很温和。信的结尾是，
I lay beside you and whispered goodnight, my sweet darling. Let us drift away to paradise in our dreams and wake up together to a new and wonderful day. I kiss you gently and fall asleep in your arms. Okay, obviously cheesy. Don Lowry was not a gifted writer, but he was a gifted manipulator. When I first heard about the story, I assumed the men who signed up for the letters from the angels must have been such easy marks, so naive, who else would buy such absurd fantasies. But then I read the dozens and dozens of letters that Pamela sent Jesse. He saved them in
我躺在你身旁，轻声说晚安，我亲爱的甜心。让我们在梦中飘向天堂，一起醒来迎接美好崭新的一天。我温柔地吻你，在你的怀里睡去。好吧，这显然很俗气。唐·洛里不是一个有天赋的作家，但他是一个天才的操纵者。当我第一次听到这个故事时，我以为那些注册接收天使来信的男人一定很容易受骗，太天真了，否则谁会买账这种荒谬的幻想呢？但后来我读了帕梅拉写给杰西的几十封信。他把这些信保存在
a large binder, each letter in its own plastic sleeve. And as I read the letters, I started to understand the power of the psychological tools Don used to hook men like Jesse. Most of the letters aren't epic fantasies. Most are about the minutia of Pamela's life. She goes to the bank, she talks to co-workers, she tells Jesse her thoughts on televangelis. Over and over Pamela tells Jesse how much he means to her, she praises him, encourages him. When you read the letters one after the other, like Jesse did day after day after day, it
一个大文件夹里，每封信都有自己的塑料封套。当我阅读这些信件时，我开始理解唐用来吸引像杰西这样的男人的心理工具的力量。大多数信件都不是史诗般的幻想。大部分内容都是关于帕梅拉生活的琐事。她去银行，她和同事交谈，她告诉杰西她对电视布道者的看法。帕梅拉一次又一次地告诉杰西他对她有多重要，她赞美他，鼓励他。当你像杰西那样日复一日地一封接一封地阅读这些信件时，它
paints a picture that feels real. I felt the Pamela and the letters was a real person, and I knew Dawn was writing them. There were other tricks. In one letter, Pamela asked Jessie to keep a picture of hers nearby as he read her letters, so he would feel she was in the room with him. Jessie put up two photos of her on the wall. She once sent him a dime. In that letter, she told Jessie she had just had a strange day. Another driver bashed her car, but didn't leave a note. Just when it looked like the day couldn't get any worse, she lost her purse. Depressed, Pamela spotted this very dime on the street.
描绘出一幅感觉真实的画面。我觉得信中的帕梅拉是一个真实的人，我知道是唐在写这些信。还有其他的把戏。在一幅信中，帕梅拉让杰西在读信时把她的照片放在附近，这样他就会觉得她和他在同一个房间里。杰西把她的两张照片贴在墙上。她曾寄给他一角钱硬币。在那封信里，她告诉杰西她刚度过了奇怪的一天。另一个司机撞了她的车，却没留字条。正当看起来这一天不能再糟的时候，她丢了钱包。沮丧的帕梅拉在街上发现了这枚硬币。
She picked it up, hoping it was a lucky charm. Later, a little boy showed up with her purse. A woman called and took responsibility for the car. Pamela told Jessie she was giving him her lucky dime. Here's Jesse reading from the end of that letter. Keep this dime darling. Letters always remind you that good people can still come into your life and good things can still happen to you and also think of this as a small token of my affection for you. If you hold it in your hand and squeeze it hard you feel the warmth of my love for you. If you hold it in your hand, it squeeze it hard, you
她把它捡起来，希望它能成为一个幸运符。后来，一个小男孩带着她的钱包出现了。一个女人打电话承认了撞车的事。帕梅拉告诉杰西她要把她的幸运硬币送给他。这是杰西在朗读那封信的结尾。留着这枚硬币吧，亲爱的。信件总是提醒你，好人仍然会走进你的生活，美好的事情仍然会发生在你身上，也把这当作我对你的一点小小爱意。如果你把它握在手里，用力挤压，你就会感受到我对你的爱的温暖。如果你把它握在手里，用力挤压，你
feel the warmth of my love coming out of it." Did you actually do that, Jesse? Yes, I think I did do that in everything. Like I said, Jesse's mother had recently died, and his dad had heart trouble. He spent a lot of time looking after him. He wrote letters to Pamela confiding in her about his depression. She sent him heartfelt letters about bad relationships she'd had, and she told him about visiting her grandfather who was suffering from dementia. That really took its toll on her, so I kind of bonded with that knowing that she was going through the same thing that I was.
会感受到我的爱从中散发出来的温暖。”你真的那么做了吗，杰西？是的，我想我什么都照做了。就像我说的，杰西的母亲最近去世了，他的父亲有心脏病。他花了很多时间照顾他。他给帕梅拉写信，向她倾诉自己的抑郁。她给他写了真挚的信，讲述了她经历过的糟糕关系，她还向他讲述了去看望患有痴呆症的祖父的事。那真的对她打击很大，所以我对此产生了共鸣，知道她正在经历和我一样的事情。
Me and her kind of more or less bonded more than any other person I've ever talked to. It was kind of like beacon from outside. It was like if you were a ship out at sea and you were looking for a lighthouse which they used that in the deal to look for the light and everything and guide yourself towards it where you know that you'll have save Haven. I'm not sure I'm exactly following you. Is this something from one of the letters where they basically talk about the lighthouse? Yes, in fact I
我和她之间的某种情感共鸣，比我交谈过的任何其他人都深。这有点像外面的一座灯塔。就像如果你是一艘在海上的船，你在寻找灯塔——他们在这场骗局中也用了这个比喻来寻找光芒之类的，并指引自己走向它，在那里你知道你会有一个安全的避风港。我不太确定我是否完全理解你的意思。这是信中提到的关于灯塔的内容吗？是的，事实上我
got a little wooden figure of a lighthouse that she sent to me at one time and everything. I said, let this be can know that somebody's out there looking out for you and everything. If Jesse had wanted to see it, there were plenty of signs the letters were mass-produced. They looked typed, but the paper doesn't have the indentations that come from tie-priter keys. The signatures look like they've been stamped or printed. All the specifics in the letters are about Pamela's life. In the letters that Pamela ever asked you how you were handling your mom's death? I'm not that I remember now, I don't think so.
有一个小木质灯塔雕像，她当时寄给我的。我说，让这成为灯塔，知道外面有人在关照你。如果杰西想看的话，有很多迹象表明这些信件是批量生产的。它们看起来像是打出来的，但纸张没有打字机按键留下的压痕。签名看起来像是盖章或打印的。信件中的所有具体细节都是关于帕梅拉的生活的。帕梅拉在信中问过你如何应对母亲的去世吗？我不记得了，现在看来，我觉得没有。
Did she ask how your dad's health was? I'm not that I remember no, I don't think so. Did she ask how your dad's health was? Not that I remember it this time, no. In fact, when I read Pamela's letters to Jessie, she never mentions any of the things he's told her. When Pamela talks about Jessie's life, she switches into generalities. I know you're sad, I know you're lonely, I know you're having a hard time. The only way the letters are personalized is that Jesse's name is sprinkled throughout,
她问过你爸爸的健康状况吗？我不记得了，没有，我觉得没有。她问过你爸爸的健康状况吗？我不记得这次问过，没有。事实上，当我读帕梅拉写给杰西的信时，她从未提及他告诉过她的任何事情。当帕梅拉谈到杰西的生活时，她会切换到泛泛而谈。我知道你很难过，我知道你很孤独，我知道你正经历艰难时期。信件唯一被个性化的地方就是杰西的名字散落在各处，
autofill, like a madlib sheet. To Jesse it didn't matter. He saw what he wanted to see. At the time, I wasn't really fully absorbing all of that. I had a lot of my plate kind of in turmoil with everything that was going on. So I just read them and it kind of took some like encourage them, encourage them out of it. Did you ever have doubts about what was going on as you were receiving the letters? Well, no, not at the time and everything like I said, I was glad to be in letters from somebody,
就像填空题一样自动填充。对杰西来说这并不重要。他看到了他想看到的东西。当时，我并没有完全吸收所有这些。我有很多事情要处理，一切都乱成一团。所以我只是读了它们，它在某种程度上给我带来了一些鼓励，让我振作起来。在收到信件的过程中，你有没有对发生的事情产生过怀疑？嗯，没有，当时没有，就像我说的，我很高兴能收到某人的信，
and even though you're paying money for that, because you have blinders on and not really paying attention to all of that. Like I said, when you're not the best-looking person in the world, that somebody out of the blue, the right to you, and tell you things, and kind of build up your spirits and everything and stuff, because everybody looks at you and stuff, it's kind of like the deal with a hunchback of Notre Dame, you'll never find anybody that'll care for you,
即使为此付了钱，因为你戴着眼罩，并没有真正注意到所有这些。就像我说的，当你不是世界上最好看的人时，有人突然给你写信，对你诉说，并有点提振你的精神之类的，因为每个人都在看着你，这有点像《巴黎圣母院》里的驼背，你永远找不到会关心你的人，
but they are at the end, they wound up making a friend with the people that befriended him and everything. At a certain point Pamela became the thing that kept Jesse afloat when he had to work long hours, when he had to close his restaurant and rush his father to the hospital. I, yes, there was one thing that really kind of touched me in everything I was telling I'm ready to give up and everything. She just told me, get back on your feet and everything, so that really was the word of encouragement and everything.
但在最后，他们最终与那些对他们友善的人成为了朋友。在某个时刻，帕梅拉成了让杰西在不得不长时间工作、不得不关闭餐馆并急忙将父亲送往医院时支撑下去的精神支柱。我，是的，有一件事真的让我很感动，我当时告诉她我准备放弃了。她只是告诉我，重新振作起来，所以那真的是一句鼓励的话。
As Don went on, he realized his members were hooked and he could take the fantasy further, much further. He invented an epic world for his angels with a magical back story and a fantastic future. Here's how it worked. The angels supposedly lived together in a retreat hidden away from the world, most were lost souls escaping drugs and bad men. These were women who needed a steady hand and a strong shoulder. As he invented more angels, Don came up with interweaving backstories. Some angels were good, some bad, angels helped one another, backstabbed each other.
随着时间的推移，唐意识到他的会员们已经上钩了，他可以把幻想推得更远，远得多。他为他的天使们创造了一个史诗般的世界，有着神奇的背景故事和奇妙的未来。它是这样运作的。天使们据说住在一个隐蔽的世外桃源里，大多数都是逃避毒品和坏男人的迷失灵魂。这些是需要稳健的双手和坚实肩膀的女性。随着他发明越来越多的天使，唐想出了交织在一起的背景故事。有些天使是好的，有些是坏的，天使们互相帮助，背后捅刀子。
All the men who signed up to join the Lonely Hats Club understood they were joining an organization of good-hearted men who were devoted to taking care of the angels. The organization was known as the Kha'ul. Don promised members of members of the Kaul that they would one day move with the angels to a valley paradise into a giant building shaped like a naked woman lying down on the grass. This lady-shaped building would house meeting rooms and auditoriums. The paradise was to be called Shandaza. In exchange for their contributions, the members would have their needs looked after at Shandaza, all their needs. At the center of the entire fantasy was a matriarch, a saintly woman named Mother Maria. Maria collected and
所有报名加入孤独帽子俱乐部的男人们都明白，他们加入的是一个心地善良的男人组织，致力于照顾天使们。这个组织被称为卡乌尔（Kaul）。唐向卡乌尔的成员们承诺，他们终有一天会和天使们一起搬到一个山谷天堂里，住进一座巨大的建筑物里，形状就像一个躺在草地上的裸体女人。这座女性形状的建筑将容纳会议室和礼堂。这个天堂将被命名为尚达萨（Shandaza）。作为他们贡献的回报，会员们在尚达萨的需求将得到照顾，所有的需求。整个幻想的中心是一位女族长，一个名叫玛丽亚母亲的圣洁女人。玛丽亚收集和
managed the money from the members and she organized and disciplined the angels. She was set to have mystical powers and could re-virginize fallen women. There were photos of Mother Maria. She was beautiful. Maria's photos were actually of a woman named Esther. She was Don's wife. Not all the members of the call believed in Shandaza. Jesse stuffed the letters describing Shandaza in the back pocket of the binder.
管理会员们的资金，并组织和管束天使们。据说她拥有神秘的力量，能够让堕落的女性恢复纯洁。有玛丽亚母亲的照片。她很漂亮。玛丽亚的照片其实是一个叫埃丝特的女人。她是唐的妻子。并非卡乌尔的所有成员都相信尚达萨。杰西把描述尚达萨的信塞进了文件夹的后口袋里。
He figured it was just some wacky idea Pamela had and just ignored it. But there were other fish who found this hook tempting. In my mind, I always held this area of, tried not to be convinced, you know, 100% about it, you know. I surely, you know, it's too good to be true. This is Ken Blanchard. He's a big gentle man and was another member of the call for many years. He was single when he joined, and he was still single when I met him in 2012.
他认为这只是帕梅拉的一些古怪想法，就没理会它。但还有其他鱼觉得这个诱饵很诱人。在我的脑海里，我一直保持着这种态度，尽量不让自己完全被说服，你知道的。我当然知道，这好得有些不真实。这是肯·布兰查德。他是一个温和的大块头，多年来一直是卡乌尔的另一位成员。他加入时是单身，2012年我见到他时依然单身。
What was the draw? What did you tell yourself when you said this is too good to be true? Well, I think with me it was the prospect of maybe at least having some sort of communication with some women, maybe my age, maybe a little bit too young for me, maybe even then. But it sounds like a kind of a neat idea to be kind of on the leading edge of something like that. Oh, geez, I don't know. Well, I don't know what else to try to explain by part of it
吸引力是什么？当你对自己说这好得难以置信时，你是怎么想的？嗯，我想对我和我来说，可能是希望能与一些女性有某种交流，也许是和我差不多的年纪，也许比我小一点点，甚至当时就是这样。但这听起来像是个好主意，能够处于某种潮流的前沿。噢，天哪，我不知道。嗯，我不知道该怎么解释我的一部分
or belief in it or anything. They got me hooked on what they were saying and everything. I believe them. We're saying everything, and I believe them, son. Don got hundreds of new signups every year. Millions of dollars float back to Don's headquarters in Malin, Illinois. He bought himself expensive cars, a Rolls Royce, and a Mercedes.
或者对它的信仰之类的。他们让我沉迷于他们所说的话。我相信他们。我们说着一切，我相信他们，孩子。唐每年都有数百名新注册会员。数百万美元流入唐位于伊利诺伊州莫林的总部。他给自己买了好车，一辆劳斯莱斯和一辆梅赛德斯。
He bought his sons and estuary everything they wanted. He got a big office in downtown Malin and operated a print shop. He hired assistants, salespeople, and ghost writers to expand his operation. By the mid-1980s, Don was writing love letters to more than 30,000 men. We had lawyers, doctors, professors, mechanics, bakers, you name them. All kinds of people, remember. We even had a priest join the call. Really?
他给他的儿子和埃丝特他们想要的一切。他在莫林市中心租了一个大办公室，经营一家印刷厂。他雇用了助理、销售人员和代笔人来扩展业务。到20世纪80年代中期，唐正在给3万多名男性写情书。我们有律师、医生、教授、机械师、面包师，应有尽有。各种各样的人，记住。我们甚至有一个牧师加入了卡乌尔。真的吗？
Wait, it's not a Catholic priest. Yeah, Catholic priest. What was he hoping to get out of it? Who the hell knows? There was probably this board. To exploit this growing market, Don constantly experimented with news, schemes and products. He started selling cassette tapes where the angels flirty with the men. He got into merch. Monks, puzzles, commemorative coins, all with angels faces printed on them. And we sent out a pillowcase with angels wearing his face on. It's an angry sleep with with angels every night.
等等，不是天主教神父。是的，天主教神父。他希望能从中得到什么？鬼才知道。可能就是这种好奇。为了开拓这个不断增长的市场，唐不断试验新的计划和产品。他开始出售天使们与男人们调情的磁带。他涉足周边商品。僧侣、拼图、纪念币，上面都印着天使的脸。我们还寄出一个印有天使脸庞的枕套。这样每晚都能和天使一起入睡。
Oh, I know all things I can. The members won just sending in cash and checks. They were sending gifts. Ken sent Angel Vanessa a windbreaker. Others sent coats and shoes. Even gardening equipment so the angels could grow vegetables at their secret retreat. Did you encourage them to send personal items? No, no.
哦，我知道我能做的一切。会员们寄来的不仅仅是现金和支票。他们还寄礼物。肯寄给天使凡妮莎一件风衣。其他人寄了外套和鞋子。甚至还有园艺设备，以便天使们可以在他们的秘密世外桃源里种蔬菜。你鼓励他们寄私人物品吗？不，不。
I hated that. Here's a guy, his wife died. And she left all kinds of jewelry and dresses and so on. I put them in a big cardboard box and mallet to us. What the hell are we going to do with it? Now what you wanted of course was you wanted them to send a check. Yes of course, or money or a cash or anything. Did you tell them not to do it?
我很讨厌那样。这有个家伙，他的妻子去世了。她留下了各种各样的珠宝、连衣裙等等。他把它们装进一个大纸箱里寄给我们。我们到底要拿它怎么办？现在你想要的当然是让他们寄支票。是的，当然，或者是钱或现金之类的。你告诉他们不要这样做吗？
Very subtly. I didn't want to hurt their feelings. They thought they were doing a great thing for the individuals by saying that these clothes. And the animal I heard of is. My dad would blaze in Leijas. He would have sidewalks sales. lingerie and gifts and jewelry. This is Don Sun, Riko Laury. And my dad would blaze in Leijas. He would be selling the lingerie on racks in front of the print shop. He would actually put up racksie on racks in front of the print shop. He would actually put up racks on the sidewalk in front of the print shop? Yep. Yep. My dad had a very sarcastic and wicked sense of humor.
非常委婉地。我不想伤害他们的感情。他们以为通过寄这些衣服是在为这些个人做一件伟大的事。而我听说过的动物是。我爸爸会在台阶上摆摊。他会搞路边大减价。内衣、礼物和珠宝。这是唐的儿子，里科·洛里。我爸爸会在台阶上摆摊。他会在印刷厂门前的架子上卖内衣。他实际上会在印刷厂门前的马路上架起架子吗？是的。是的。我爸爸有着非常讽刺和恶毒的幽默感。
A local police officer told me men from all over the country started showing up in Malin asking where they could find the angels. If they found their way to the print shop, Don called the cops on them. Don found it police tried to explain to the man that there was no angel Vanessa, no retreat, no shondaza. But occasionally, if Don was in the mood, he'd actually allow them to meet female employees whom he had asked to pose as angels in photos. In time, Don even set up events for his most loyal members to meet the angels. He called them gatherings. At the gathering in Chicago, an advice columnist offered dating suggestions, a comedian told
当地的一名警官告诉我，来自全国各地的男人们开始出现在莫林，询问在哪里可以找到天使。如果他们找到了印刷厂，唐就会报警。唐发现警察试图向这些人解释根本没有天使凡妮莎、没有隐居地、也没有尚达萨。但偶尔，如果唐有心情，他实际上会允许他们与他要求在照片中冒充天使的女员工见面。随着时间的推移，唐甚至为他最忠诚的会员举办了活动来见天使。他称之为聚会。在芝加哥的聚会上，一位专栏作家提供了约会建议，一位喜剧演员讲了
jokes. Angels and yellow-green dresses leapt around on stage in an interpretive dance. Jesse went to the Moline gathering. He was excited to finally meet Pamela. She looked just like she did in her pictures. In fact, she was one of Don's employees, and her name really was Pamela. She looked just like she did in her pictures. In fact, she was one of Don's employees, and her name really was Pamela. She greeted Jessie warmly. But Jessie's excitement was tempered by the fact that there were a dozen other
笑话。穿着黄绿色长裙的天使们在舞台上跳着表现性舞蹈。杰西去了莫林的聚会。他很高兴终于能见到帕梅拉。她看起来和照片里一模一样。事实上，她是唐的一名员工，她的名字确实叫帕梅拉。她看起来和照片里一模一样。事实上，她是唐的一名员工，她的名字确实叫帕梅拉。她热情地迎接了杰西。但杰西的兴奋被这样一个事实冲淡了：现场还有十几个
men at the gathering. Jessie was shocked to find that every man thought he was in a personal relationship with Pamela too. They crowded around her, vying for her attention. And then that's when it dawned on me and said, hey, this is not what I thought it would be or anything. That it was a ripoff. Well, that was kind of like getting a kick in the stomach. It was upsetting and everything.
聚会上的男士。杰西震惊地发现，每个男人都以为自己也和帕梅拉有着私人的恋爱关系。他们挤在她周围，争夺她的注意力。然后就在那时我恍然大悟，心想，嘿，这根本不是我想象的那样。这是一场骗局。好吧，那感觉就像肚子挨了一脚。令人沮丧等等。
We sent all that money in this net and the other end. It wasn't what it was meant to be. It got you down to reality and stuff. So Jesse knew that Pamela lacked music boxes so he bought an expensive one with a tiny record on it that played when the Saints go marching in. Pamela loved it. He says she stared at it and let the record play. It went on and on and on. The other men stood around them and looked at Jessie. They looked at Pamela, then back to Jessie. He liked that he was making them jealous. Jessie didn't blame Pamela. He wasn't exactly sure how the scam worked, but he was sure that the woman standing before him was the same woman who wrote to him
我们把所有的钱都投进去了，结果却是这样。这根本不是它本来的样子。它把你拉回了现实等等。所以杰西知道帕梅拉喜欢音乐盒，于是他买了一个昂贵的音乐盒，上面有一个小唱片，当播放《圣徒行进曲》时会转动。帕梅拉很喜欢它。他说她盯着它看，让唱片一直播放。一遍又一遍。其他男人站在他们周围看着杰西。他们看着帕梅拉，然后又看着杰西。他喜欢自己让他们嫉妒。杰西不怪帕梅拉。他不太确定这个骗局是如何运作的，但他确信眼前这个女人就是给他写信的那个女人
That she was the one who had read his letters the proof Pamela's dog jumped into his lap She jumped on my lap twice and everything that really surprised Pamela and that So I guess she smelled my scent on the letters. I was writing to her and everything and stuff We got in touch with Pamela to see if she remembered any of this, but she declined to be interviewed on tape for the story. She did confirm that she hadn't written the letters.
她就是读过他的信的人。证据是帕梅拉的狗跳上了他的膝盖。她跳到我膝上两次，这真的让帕梅拉很惊讶，所以我想她闻到了我写给她的信上的气味。我们联系了帕梅拉，想看看她是否还记得这些，但她拒绝接受采访并录音。她确实证实了她没有写过这些信。
Jesse made friends with a couple of other men at the meeting, particularly two guys named Lenny and Al. They were all like strangers who had independently watched the same soap opera for many years. Well, we got to talking about it and say, well, why did you write on to this and everything independently watched the same soap opera for many years. So we stayed in correspondence like they said. They wrote me letters. They even called me at my restaurant to ask me how things were going and everything. And finding out, asking about my dad and everything so that kind of was encouraging to hear somebody calling to want to check on you and everything. In other words, they asked about all the personal stuff Pamela never asked about. Lenny and Al stayed in touch until they died. What finally brought Don Lowry's cam to an end was a woman named Susan Rassow. She was
杰西在会上和另外几个男人交朋友了，特别是两个叫伦尼和阿尔的家伙。他们就像是各自独立观看了多年同一部肥皂剧的陌生人。嗯，我们开始讨论它，并说，好吧，为什么你要写信给这个等等，各自独立观看了多年同一部肥皂剧的肥皂剧。所以我们保持着联系，就像他们说的那样。他们给我写信。他们甚至打电话到我的餐馆问我最近怎么样等等。了解并询问我爸爸的情况等等，所以听到有人打电话来关心你感觉很鼓舞。换句话说，他们问了所有帕梅拉从未问过的私人问题。伦尼和阿尔一直与他保持联系，直到他们去世。最终结束唐·洛里骗局的是一个名叫苏珊·拉索的女人。她
a model that Don had worked with. She had gotten into a car crash and called Don for help. He showed up at the hospital with a photographer. The unbounded her wounds and took pictures. They sent these to all the men who were corresponding with the Angel Susan and asked them for help in paying her medical bills. But Don didn't give Susan the money. She went to the cops.
是唐曾合作过的一位模特。她遭遇了一场车祸，打电话向唐求助。他带着摄影师出现在医院。他解开她的伤口并拍照。他们把这些寄给所有与天使苏珊通信的男人们，并请求他们帮忙支付医疗费用。但唐没有把钱给苏珊。她报警了。
And she came to our office. She revealed the promise Mr. Lowry had made to her and broken. The return that Mr. Lowry received was staggering in terms of dollars and cents. This is Lieutenant Kenneth Rex Roth of the Malene Police Department. He'd been aware of Don Lowry for years. He turned away many men who'd come to the police station in search of the Moline Police Department. He'd been aware of Don Lowry for years. He turned away many men who'd come to the police station
她来到了我们的办公室。她揭露了洛里先生对她做出却又违背的承诺。洛里先生获得的回报在美元和美分上是惊人的。这是莫林警察局的肯尼斯·雷克斯罗斯中尉。他多年来一直知道唐·洛里的存在。他拒绝了许多来到警察局寻找莫林警察局的人。他多年来一直知道唐·洛里的存在。他赶走了许多来到警察局
and search for the angels. And he'd been looking for a way to lock Don up. He was very diabolical. He's a sinister person. I consider Mr. Lowry to be an evil man. But thanks to Susan Rassow, the police finally had evidence to obtain subpoenas. They raided Don's print shop.
寻找天使的男人们。他一直在寻找一种能将唐关起来的方法。他非常恶毒。他是一个险恶的人。我认为洛里先生是一个邪恶的人。但多亏了苏珊·拉索，警方终于有了获得传票的证据。他们突击搜查了唐的印刷厂。
They found out that some men sold everything in order to give their life savings to the angels. One man lived out of his car and forwarded his social security check to his angel. When the police got in touch with these guys, many of them realized for the first time that their treasured letters were written by a man. Well, what I was turned out to be angry about and more embarrassed about more than anything was the fact that he was even involved. Any man at all was even involved. Again, this is Ken Blanchard, who spent years receiving letters from Angel Vanessa.
他们发现有些男人卖掉了一切，只为了把毕生积蓄交给天使。有一个人住在车里，把他的社保支票寄给他的天使。当警察联系到这些人时，他们中的许多人第一次意识到他们珍视的信件是一个男人写的。嗯，我感到愤怒和尴尬的地方，比什么都重要的是，我竟然卷入了其中。任何男人竟然都卷入了其中。再次说明，这是肯·布兰查德，他多年来一直收到天使凡妮莎的来信。
When I found out that these letters I'd been getting all these times, and I thought it was some girl sharing something with me. Well, then I find out is him writing the darn thing. You know, I thought, my God, what the hell am I getting into? But I can laugh about now, but I think at the time I did have some feelings about that that weren't very charitable. about that, they weren't very charitable. Don's lawyer said that if members believed the angels were real, that was on them. As Don told me many years later,
当我发现这些信件我一直收到，并且我以为是个女孩在跟我分享什么。嗯，然后我发现是他在写该死的东西。你知道，我心想，天哪，我到底卷入了什么鬼东西？但我现在可以一笑了之，但我想当时我对那些事情确实有一些很不宽容的情绪。对此，它们很不宽容。唐的律师说，如果会员们相信天使是真的，那是他们自己的事。正如唐多年后告诉我的，
People believe what they want to believe. You cannot dissuade them. Most members believe the angels lived forever and a never-never land called to retreat. We told them they lived forever and never grew old. Does that tell you anything? Huh? Well, you're surprised that they believed you?
人们相信他们愿意相信的。你无法劝说他们改变。大多数会员相信天使永远活在虚构国度“隐居地”里。我们告诉他们她们长生不老、永葆青春。这能说明什么吗？啊？好吧，你很惊讶他们相信了你吗？
Yeah. It has helped them, I mean, I'm happy, so big deal. Don and Pamela were charged with male fraud, conspiracy, and money laundering. The press mobbed the trial. Don was shamed in the press, called a snake oil salesman at People magazine. Which brings me back to what got me interested
是的。这帮助了他们，我的意思是，我很开心，所以这算什么大事。唐和帕梅拉被控邮件诈骗、共谋和洗钱。媒体蜂拥至审判现场。唐在媒体前颜面扫地，被《人物》杂志称为江湖骗子。这让我回到了让我产生兴趣的地方
in the story in the first place, the thing that really surprised me. Many members flew from all over the country to show up at the courthouse in defense of the call Some stood outside with picket science defending the brotherhood Jesse and his friend Al were both there as they waited outside the courtroom. Jesse saw Pamela come up He rushed over to her. She was walking up and I noticed she was cold so I took off my Jacket and draped it over her shoulders and we walked all the way up to the courthouse
最初的故事，最让我惊讶的事情。许多会员从全国各地飞来，出现在法院外为卡乌尔辩护。一些人拿着纠察标语站在外面捍卫兄弟会。杰西和他的朋友阿尔都在那里。当他们在法庭外等待时，杰西看到帕梅拉走了过来。他冲了过去。她走过来，我注意到她很冷，所以我脱下夹克披在她的肩膀上，我们一直走到法院。
I was kind of like a security guard, and after she went indoors I took my coat off and I backed off and everything. Did she say anything to you at that point? No not really. Members testified on the stand and said the call had been a critical, beautiful part of their lives. One man said letters from the angel had been a critical, beautiful part of their lives. One man said letters from the angel saved him from alcoholism and thoughts of suicide. Jesse testified, too.
我有点像个保安，等她进去后，我脱下外套，退了回去。她当时对你说了什么吗？没有，真的没有。会员们在证人席上作证说，卡乌尔是他们生活中至关重要、美丽的一部分。一个人说天使的信是他们生活中至关重要、美丽的一部分。一个人说天使的信挽救了他免于酗酒和自杀倾向。杰西也作证了。
This is him reading a court transcript of what he said on the stand. Well, it gave you, like I said, inspiration to continue, or no matter what the circumstances that you were going through, that if you preserved, you could make it. Do you remember saying this at the trial? Yes, I do. Would you say that you still stand by what you said at trial? Yes. So here's the thing, Jesse. You know, Don Lowry lied to you and sent you letters on behalf of someone else for many years and you formed an
这是他朗读他在证人席上所说的话的法庭记录。嗯，它给了你，就像我说的，继续前进的灵感，无论你经历什么情况，只要你坚持下去，你就能成功。你还记得在审判时说过这些话吗？是的，我记得。你会说你仍然支持你在审判时说过的话吗？是的。所以事情是这样的，杰西。你知道，唐·洛里欺骗了你，多年来一直代表别人给你写信，而你与
Emotional connection with this woman who was writing to you When at the same time you showed up at trial to essentially defend Don Lowry and I'm trying to understand how and why you did that Well like I said before it wasn't actually defending him, but it was actually Pamela that was the one that we were all, we turned our attention to help her, and that meant helping Dawn also when everything. I understand that Dawn was really the mastermind of the operation, but when she showed up at these meetings and she presented herself as the same Pamela who was the Pamela and
这个给你写信的女人建立了情感联系，与此同时你却出现在法庭上基本上是为了捍卫唐·洛里，我在努力理解你是如何以及为什么要这么做的。嗯，就像我之前说的，实际上并不是在捍卫他，而是实际上帕梅拉才是我们所有人将注意力转向去帮助的人，这也意味着顺便也帮助了唐。我明白唐确实是整个行动的幕后策划者，但当她出现在这些聚会上并表现得自己就是信中那个帕梅拉时。
the letters. Wasn't she lying to you? Well, I guess you could think about that that way, yes. Did you ever think about it that way? I know, not until now and everything. We're in all of this has been re-broad out and everything. This has been re-broad out in everything. Don and Pamela were both found guilty. Pamela served two years in prison. Don was in prison for ten years. When I met Don, I asked him whether he felt he did anything wrong.
难道她没有对你撒谎吗？嗯，我想你可以这么想，是的。你有没有这么想过？我知道，直到现在才这样。这一切都被重新翻出来播出了。这一切都被重新翻出来播出了。唐和帕梅拉都被判定有罪。帕梅拉在监狱里服刑两年。唐在监狱里呆了十年。我见到唐时，问他是否觉得自己做了什么错事。
I think I did something very wrong. I suppose I made it a little bit too real. I did. I made it too real. Jesse lives alone now with his dog, Chubaka. He's in his 60s and is still single. He's had some complications from diabetes recently and had parts of his foot amputated. It hasn't been easy. My producer, Stephanie Foug, visited him at his house in Texas.
我想我做了一件非常错误的事。我想我把它弄得太真实了。我确实这么做了。我把它弄得太真实了。杰西现在和他的狗楚巴卡独自生活。他六十多岁了，依然单身。他最近有一些糖尿病并发症，脚趾被截肢了一部分。这并不容易。我的制片人斯蒂芬妮·富格去他在德克萨斯州的家中探望了他。
I was in the hospital after my amputation running around on my niece scooter. Said, you can still do this, keep going and everything. So, remember those words she told me, get on your feet. So, I do that and everything and keep going. Wow. Even now, even today. Even today and everything and stuff. So, but basically that line, you know, get on your your feet it doesn't really matter who wrote it.
我在截肢手术后躺在医院里，坐在侄女的滑板车上四处转悠。她说，你还是可以做到这一点，坚持下去等等。所以，记住她告诉我的那些话，站起来。所以我照做了等等，然后继续前进。哇。即使在现在，甚至在今天。甚至在今天等等。所以，基本上那句话，你知道，站起来，谁写的其实并不重要。
No. You think back but it brings back fond memories of way back when and you could be in your hundreds and everything or older and I hope to have this on my mind on down the line and everything and stuff so. Jesse still has the little wooden lighthouse Pamela sent him. It's on his dresser in his bedroom. And he still has two photos of Pamela and his Dan, one on the wall, one on his desk. In one, she's sitting in an office chair, hands in her lap, not glamorous or sexy or anything. Jesse says, she's just sitting there being herself. It's just a little something to say.
没有。你会回想起来，但它唤起了对很久以前的美好回忆，你可能会活到一百岁甚至更老，我希望在未来的日子里能把这个记在心里等等。杰西还留着帕梅拉送给他的那个小木制灯塔。它放在他卧室的梳妆台上。他还留着两张帕梅拉的照片在墙上和桌上。其中一张里，她坐在办公椅上，双手放在膝上，既不迷人也不性感。杰西说，她只是坐在那里做她自己。这只是一个小小的纪念。
I made a friend. Thanks this week to the many people in this American life and NPR who helped put the story together, Ira Glass, Brian Reed, Joel Lovell, Matt Turnie, Neil Drumming, and Robin Semi-N, also Anne Goodenkoff, Karamolka Galison, Maggie Pennman, and the NPR library. A special shout-out to Stephanie Foo, officially she was the producer of the story, unofficially, I think of her as a force of nature. If this is your first time joining us and you like what you heard, you may want to check out episode three of Hidden Brain, it's about a woman competing in a man's world. I'm Shankar Vidanthan, and this is NPR. Thanks for listening to Hidden Brain. We have something really special to tell you about. This is NPR. movies, books, TV shows, music, and more. JK Rowling is on Pop Culture Happy Hour.
我交到了一个朋友。本周感谢《This American Life》和NPR的许多人为这个故事的制作提供帮助，包括Ira Glass、Brian Reed、Joel Lovell、Matt Turnie、Neil Drumming和Robin Semi-N，还有Anne Goodenkoff、Karamolka Galison、Maggie Pennman以及NPR资料馆。特别鸣谢Stephanie Foo，官方身份她是这个故事的制作人，非官方地，我认为她是一个自然力量。如果这是你第一次收听我们的节目并且喜欢你所听到的内容，你可能想去看看Hidden Brain的第三期节目，它讲的是一个女性在男性主导的世界中竞争的故事。我是Shankar Vidanthan，这里是NPR。感谢收听Hidden Brain。我们有一件非常特别的事情要告诉你们。这里是NPR。电影、书籍、电视节目、音乐等等。J.K.罗琳做客Pop Culture Happy Hour。
Listen now at npr.org slash podcasts and on the NPR-1 app. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
立即登录 npr.org/podcasts 以及在 NPR-1 应用程序上收听。目前本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。